a chance to send the Thunder home
Lillard long range three
[Applause]
are you kidding me
Timmy honest carried a seven point lead
at the half they're up 14 right now
let's make it up 17. Damien Lillard he
did not even cross that court in the
shot down facial expression did not
change like this is an expectation
on the attack missed that one
right at The Rim radish the other way
name a deep one buried it Damian Lillard
from long range way out in the deep
water
he could shoot that three seconds left
in the quarter name steps through D3 on
the way
back damage from Malone
the Blazer can catch dribble and then
get it off if he needs to no dribble
name from Deep yes sir name from way
downtown game distance and he finishes
the quarter
being very conservative of course with
his minutes
came outside no one open time running
down 11 on the shot clock drills a three
what is that two strides past mid Court
nothing but neck Blazers looking to pile
on that lead to 65-42 Dava three yeah
are you kidding me
Hornet's last basket came with a 709
Mark at this third quarter
goodness Damian Lillard from 38 feet
and reminder Rivers five thousands he
tries to defend Lillard
Lillard another huge three bucks
[Laughter]
the Blazers are back down the floor
Anthony knew where that was going
that was a great read oh Lillard from
the logo Battle quiet The Crowd Oh my
goodness
Mello had 13 points in the first half
for Portland on five of nine shootings
back on the floor here's Lillard dialing
it in from long distance baby Blazers
now lead by 12. better pick him up early
Jordan
Lillard wants to do it again oh oh
Damien Lillard
20 seconds to go in the half
you see what you started Reggie when I
started see what you started that should
be a new rule when you're up this much
you got to end it on a three if you need
three all right what's Willow picking
about here
he's thinking about him
and it's all over that's what he's
thinking about game time game time baby
try to get something going here
two seconds left Lillard from the logo
it's good
Logan
[Applause]
Jones Jr tries to go up above Giles
offensive rebound Simon's thought about
it
finds it to Dame from well before the
logo connects before the horn that was a
smart play from Anthony the reason he
didn't shoot it because he saw the clock
he's a 31 three-point shooter but he's
making more per game this year at 1.6
that at any point in his career
play alert outside the city limits
Chicago with their highest scoring
quarter of the game here in the fourth
quarter so far
dang gets it with white checking Dame
deep look from outside there's the three
are too good if you give them any kind
of space
it's a good defense by Portland yup
Williams is trying to get aggressive and
Covington oh it's deep oh logo Lillard
knocking it down oh man my goodness
start of a six-game road trip for the
places way outside what a great looking
shot put in Lillard let's give him it
from 32.
he was six of nine oh my God
that was from the NBA logo oh my
goodness what a shock you've got to be
kidding me people and it's because the
Lakers can't have that much spacing you
know why they don't have many
three-point Shooters
Damian Lillard
laces one up on the Lakers at five to
shoot a minute and a half to play that's
a bomb
oh my god oh
[Applause]
ridiculous
Damian Lillard
now Jeremy Grant around Collins tries to
finger roll and nurkic the rebound
[Applause]
wow Lillard way out any hits Boston has
now won sixth straight how about Toronto
gets win number 13 straight tonight Nick
nurse killing an outstanding job as
Lillard launches and connects a game
first
Lillard pulls up just past half court
[Applause]
they did have a four-game skid they have
won three or four since there's Lillard
again from the logo
twice you cannot stop Damian Lillard
right now he's now 10-17 tonight
Portland scores here I can see a timeout
here from Poland oh that's a free it's
an 11 nothing run you're right Carlisle
calls time with a half minute to go
coming up the American Express halftime
report what three
world
did he knock that down from Great Bend
to put 43 points on the board in the
period a three from Graham back iron
rebound trip up the game at the buzzer
[Applause]
and in this league you got to have some
people in that paint
Lillard long distance three man
do you hear how much Terry stops his
yelling run
Dave will right into about a 35-footer
Lillard 27 on the ninth three-point play
for Barnes Blazer lead at nine 5-13
remaining
Damien
how dare you
the odd Audacity Of that man
of game three and then answered with 15
in the third quarter in game four so
here's Lillard gets up the first shot
and it is true
it's got harkless and aminu down in the
corners two-man game with Cantor long
three and there comes Dame
Dame Lillard hits another bomb this
crew's not calling that
five to shoot Lillard that is a bomb he
got it
in Lillard with confidence oozing out of
his veins back in this ball game from
the three-point line Thompson has five
threes off the steal back comes Willard
guard the three
from way downtown up off his military
time now that John he's getting ready to
start now the talking we've got a ball
game here people Lily again
[Applause]
they've held the Warriors to eight
points here in the fourth quarter which
would by far be a season low Lillard
from deep hit it
it's over
this is the hardest player to guard it
might be him one-on-one because
we can get to whatever shot he wants
name way outside from the A and Arena
knocks down a triple had his injury
problems last year and again this year
averaging 13 again Lillard stand still
three from the logo
from Aurora way downtown I'm not gonna
overreact to that that's a tough shot
you got to give that got to give
something up to great players
speaking of great players Lillard from
Deep with a three
green set by Lillard into the paint
seven to shoot for Damian Lillard
is from way down
last time out and was limited because if
the Blazers could really put some
pressure on him no he's not he's not
messing around
oh three for three Damian Lillard hits
it out of the park so it's a
45-33 lead for Team Stefan
three-pointer he came off about donovitz
quite a bit of distance but look you got
Randolph two feet in the paint going
into his move CJ just wants to show and
get back ain't no help for that
they put these big guards on Miller
makes it a tough deal to pass so you
know what I'll just launch over you say
all that even sibo
[Applause]
uh Lillard left alone 13 to shoot and
snugs in a three about a 30 plus putter
for Damian Lillard
Lillard
from mid Court this will count God
[Applause]
[Music]